yep feels like a Batman Begins I wonder
if he's ever been a review Batman Begins
I wonder if he's finally gonna buy me a
unicorn
Deadpool shut up about the unicorns I'll
shut up about unicorns when you shut up
about Rachel would you two quit your
petty squabbling it's unpatriotic hey
icebox its 2017 there's nothing more
patriotic than petty squabbling don't
you watch the news
Deadpool shut the up whoo Wolvie
ever since you went rated R you got a
potty mouth Batman if you don't shut
dead pull-up I'm gonna slit all of your
throats I swear to God swear to me
admit it Nine Inch Nails you
right into that one it's amazing that I
don't have a review for this movie on my
channel it's one of my all-time favorite
movies and I think most people know that
I love that man begins I think most
everyone does love Batman Begins it's
kind of hard not to it's destined to be
a classic of the superhero genre they
got Batman right finally like yeah the
Keaton Batman's are fun and enjoyable
but besides the animated and amazing
Batman mask of the phantasm they had
never explored his origins on the big
screen before until this film and Nolan
god is so right that he changed the film
industry not just superhero in comic
book movies but a lot of other films all
had to suddenly be dark and gritty now
you can say that that's a bad thing and
in some ways it was a lot of reboots of
many things tried to be Batman Begins
and they just couldn't do it Batman
Begins was the first time that I cared
just as much about Bruce Wayne as I did
about Batman I love me some Michael
Keaton I think he's great but I never
really gave a about his Bruce Wayne
and that's partly due to the writing of
those films but in this film I cared a
lot about Wayne and his family I got to
see his upbringing his relationship
developed with his parents who of course
are tragically murdered and the
blossoming relationship with Rachel from
a very young age getting to know Alfred
and the way he suffered with dealing
with the trauma of what happened to his
parents all of that great storytelling
led to something that was really rare
for myself at the time wanting to see
more of the person behind the mask and
less of the superhero I loved Batman and
every time he's on screen kicking ass I
mean it's amazing but rarely in
superhero films at that time were you as
invested in the people behind the masks
you're usually just waiting for the
superheroes to come out and have really
awesome action scenes that's how it was
back in the day Batman Begins in Raimi
spider-man movies and Bryan Singer's
first few x-men films showed us that you
really could care about the people
behind the costumes and that comic book
movies had a lot of storytelling powers
to offer the character of Batman on the
big screen has been blessed with some
fantastic music Danny Elfman's themes
are still a conic say what you want
about Batman Forever
in Batman and Robin Elliot Goldenthal
music for those films is really good and
Hans Zimmer and James Newton Howard
combined to make my favorite Batman
theme I still listen to molasses on the
highway and that's a dangerous song to
be listening to on the highway because
you can really start speeding and I have
done that before and it's I had to be
very careful when I listen to this
soundtrack because it's just that good I
got to be honest i sat down for this
review and I was like is this really a
necessary review for me to film
everybody pretty much knows I love this
movie
critics and fans loved it too I have a
review that's on my buddy's Channel the
schmoes know we did a Batman series back
in the day back in 2012 about five years
ago I don't have one on this channel and
I wanted one on this channel an updated
one that was here on my channel for
people to watch but at the same time
what really new can I say about Batman
Begins I must be honest it's all been
said Wayne when he's training with Liam
Neeson in the mountains Ken Watanabe
that incredible sequence where he learns
to be a ninja essentially his return to
Gotham and revealing himself to Falcone
my favorite shot in the entire film as
the camera pans around Batman perched
atop a building the culmination of
people coming together in the finale to
work together as a team to get to that
great moment where Batman says I won't
kill you but I don't have to save you
it's just uh it's goosebumps everywhere
this this movie is filled with moments
like that it's also a very funny film
it's not drowned in darkness there's a
lot of great moments of humor like nice
coat and things like that that just keep
the film having some levity where you
can enjoy the experience and not feel
like you are so depressed from this
characters horrible life years later I
have barely a single flaw with this
movie that I can really pinpoint there's
one scene that has always bugged me a
very awkward edit and it's this scene
you were seen him yet yeah wait
but on the news he's back I'm sure he
realize I can't stop big machine it's
such an odd edit I never liked that from
the very beginning but that's just one
of those little nitpick moments that
doesn't have much to do with the story
but if I really got down and dirty with
trying to nitpick that man begins that
edit bugs me they got the character so
right and all these years later I've
come to appreciate the film far more
than I did when I first saw it and my
grade has also boosted since my review
with the schmoes no despite the fact
that I have given pretty much every
Christopher Nolan movie I've reviewed
except for following in this series my
highest grade I'm not going to hold back
now and lie about how I feel tapman
begins
deserves an A+ guys thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to my
review of Dunkirk very soon and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck my knife
[Music]